[Music]
nobody can teach you a language you can
only learn it
yourself my name is LCA lamparello I
don't live to learn languages I learn
languages to live a better
life each and every language one learns
is not only an opportunity for
connection but it's a way to live
multiple lives within one lifetime it's
a window a portal a path to an
experience that is beyond
words you see I did not choose to learn
languages they somehow chose me the
books beckon my brain the journals
seduced my very being and I couldn't
help but express my love in return
friendships
determination
[Music]
Focus and lots and lots of
fun by learning over a dozen languages
I've had the chance to enrich my life
with thousands of people and hundreds of
thousands of
experiences I never counted the days it
would take me to reach fluency because I
truly enjoyed the
process reading listen listening writing
and speaking but doing so in a foreign
language those simple acts nourish my
soul and fed my Hunger to become a
better version of
myself my family nurtured my curiosity
and see my grandfather's collection of
books has always been inspiring and
spellbinding my father used to say the
art of creation comes from the art of
combination and my grandmother told me
from a very young age everything you put
into your head no matter how seemingly
insignificant will come to use in the
long
[Music]
run when I think about the last 30 years
of learning languages underlining and
highlighting like a madman reading for
hours and end and feeling as if my brain
was ready to explode I feel grateful
because languages give me a
path and as long as I continued on that
path putting in the hard work and daily
effort I knew I would make little Luca
proud don't shy away from learning a
language take a chance to get to know a
better version of
[Music]
yourself happy language
learning